buonasera a tutti grazie grazie grazie
al ted grazie a gabriela per avermi
invitato questa bellissima
manifestazione
io sono qui a raccontarvi di muba come
diceva gabriella è una realtà che
parte da lontano in realtà noi abbiamo
questo video che avete visto riguarda
l'inaugurazione del museo alla rotonda
di via besana a milano del risale al
gennaio di quest'anno per cui visto così
sembra un percorso molto breve in realtà
la nostra esperienza
per quanto riguarda l'educazione non
formale dei bambini e per quanto
riguarda la volontà assoluta di voler
creare un centro per la cultura
l'educazione è
un ceto di riferimento per le famiglie
le scuole i bambini di milano e non solo
parte da molto lontano ovvero parte
dagli anni 90 quando si è creato appunto
alla prima associazione è il caso è
interessante perché comunque ci siamo
formati un gruppo di mamme
con bambini piccoli tutte provenienti da
esperienze di diverso tipo chi come nel
mio caso dalla pubblicità che dal
giornalismo chi dal marketing eccetera
con la volontà però di creare un posto
ad avere un posto fisico a milano che
seguisse un po l'esempio di quelli che
sono i children's museum presenti in
tutto il mondo
in europa noi in italia siamo un po un
fanalino di coda siamo una realtà molto
piccola
in realtà
attualmente in italia ci sono solo due
musei dei bambini che sono il nostro
explora a roma e poi c'è una realtà
all'interno di città della scienza di
napoli con l'officina dei piccoli ma è
sicuramente è questo
parlando del futuro un modello di
sviluppo che deve ancora crescere
pensate solo che in europa ce ne sono
più di centro per non parlare quello che
succede nel mondo anglosassone dove è
una realtà assolutamente molto diffusa è
molto concreta e molto di riferimento
per il territorio
cosa abbiamo fatto fino ad oggi fino
all'altro ieri quello che abbiamo fatto
un po un percorso inverso
sostanzialmente quello che ci siamo
inventate di fare è quello di creare un
modello
nuovo di
sviluppare un modello nuovo che è quello
delle mostre gioco per bambini vedete
alle mie spalle degli esempi
dimostra che abbiamo fatto in passato
laddove le mostre sono composte da
exhibit da diversi strumenti di gioco
sono vere e proprie macchine di gioco di
grandi dimensioni che hanno dietro un
lavoro molto importante dal punto di
vista anche del pensiero della strategia
del progetto architettonico della
realizzazione della scelta dei materiali
e quant'altro
abbiamo sviluppato mostra su temi seri
adulti perché comunque abbiamo sempre
cercato in questi anni di evitare le
intermediazioni di personaggi
personaggini pupazzetti pupazzini
abbiamo parlato in maniera molto chiara
diretta e oneste bambini e questo di
linguaggio che ha un linguaggio tipico
dell'educazione non formale
fa sì che attraverso il gioco contenuti
non semplici ma che vengono poi comunque
trattati poi ulteriormente naturalmente
nel percorso scolastico
riescano a passare in maniera diciamo
più morbida e comunque con degli ottimi
multati
qui dove siamo ora non è male
ci siamo fatti una discreta casetta
questa è la rotonda della besana è un
edificio storico di grande valore
uno degli edifici del settecento più
importanti di milano
che ha un passato terribile noi quando
l'abbiamo saputo ci siamo un po
spaventati fra le altre cose perchè
pensate che qui sotto un tempo c'erano
qualcosa come 150 mila cadaveri
non sto scherzando questo è stato per
tanti anni nei secoli è stato un
cimitero cioè era il foppone cosiddetto
ovvero era collegato con la cà granda
con l'ospedale
maggiore di milano ai tempi della peste
le due strutture erano collegati da un
tunnel sotterraneo che adesso in via di
verifica perché si vorrebbe aprirlo e i
morituri poveretti loro venivano malati
di paese venivano portati alla besana e
lì venivano seppelliti
dopo di che è stata per tanti anni ha
avuto altre destinazioni d'uso stata
abbandonata per un lunghissimo periodo
negli anni 40 il comune al ne ha ripreso
possesso iniziato da lavori di restauro
molto in pontano importanti per arrivare
a noi l'anno scorso ha deciso con questa
amministrazione pubblica che finalmente
si è dimostrata un pochino più aperta e
disponibile rispetto alle
amministrazioni passate di creare un
centro per la cultura permanente per i
bambini a milano
noi abbiamo partecipato a questo bando
fra virgolette oneroso
abbiamo vinto saremmo abbiamo questa
finalmente una sede
degna di tale nome dove poter offrire
continuativamente nel corso dell'anno
diversi tipi di prodotto proposte queste
come sostanzialmente suddiviso lo spazio
nella parte centrale che la parte più
importante destinata alle grandi mostre
che possono essere nostre produzioni
coproduzioni che arrivano da altri
circuiti dagli altri musei dei bambini e
così via uno spazio di laboratorio dove
è molto importante l'esperimento di re
mida cioè la sperimentazione di
materiali
tramite diversi tipi di laboratorio di
materiali di scarto di produzione
aziendale
ma contestualmente sono state aperte
anche un book shop che abbiamo affidato
edizioni corraini e un bar bistrot che
sta
affidato a che questo è un gruppo di
giovani imprenditori che sta funzionando
molto bene e tutto questo ha fatto sì
che un posto che era veramente
poco vissuto molto nel cuore dei
milanesi ma poco vissuto sia diventato
veramente un po un nuovo punto di
riferimento cittadino non solo per le
famiglie in particolar modo è bellissimo
vedere ridicola domenic sabato la
domenica mattina alle famiglie che
arrivano fanno i picnic sotto gli alberi
per noi milanesi è una cosa che non è
così facile da vedere assolutamente ma è
un posto vivo pulsante dove comunque si
sente la voglia di partecipare di fare e
questo spirito crede di partecipazione
molto presente
ecco io di questo vorrei parlarvi come
conclusione come come prospettiva per il
futuro
noi abbiamo messo in questi anni
veramente una quantità di passione e non
solo per portare avanti questo progetto
grande volontà grande voglia grande
decisione veramente contro tutto tutti
questo modello però secondo noi è
interessante c'è questa unione comunque
di unire un entità così importante del
nostro patrimonio storico che non aveva
una destinazione d'uso che era un po
così come dire lasciata lì a perdere e
darla in gestione a chi comunque in
grado poi di trarne anche del profitto
cioè di farla comunque fra virgolette
rendere questo è un lavoro che bisogna
fare assolutamente a quattro a quattro
mani con le amministrazioni pubbliche
con i ministeri eccetera eccetera con
chi di competenza ma noi siamo convinti
che possa essere un modello vincente
perché comunque
noi ci siamo riuscite perché non
dovrebbe riuscire in altre parti
d'italia
le occasioni sicuramente non mancano se
avete bisogno di come dire conforto
aiuto e tutto quello che possiamo fare
siamo qui grazie